e
bu if you could please have a seat it's
9:30 we are going to open the public
hearing for houseb 10:46 but before we
do that if everybody will please join us
Allegiance
do any representative that's joining us
today thank you
welcome and do we have a prime sponsor
certainly
good morning for the record I am Lauren
selig and I represent Durham which is
straford County District 10 and I am
simply reading uh 1046 FN which is an
act requiring a boat owner who is not
the operator to notify law enforcement
and file an accident report in certain
circumstances and um that's all I can
tell you about the bill
dir
good morning my name's Josh dir I'm one
of
the oh so I don't have to hold it okay
this is my first time here so I I
apologize okay no problem good morning
um Madam chair and other members of the
committee uh my name is Josh Earth I am
a sergeant with New Hampshire State
Police Marine Patrol I'm here to speak
to House Bill 1046 which is basically
ads teeth to an existing statute um that
would require the registered owner or
the owner of a boat to report um a
reportable boating accident I think the
couple of key takeaways here to this is
it could be property damage only we had
a case like that if I was to recall your
attention back to this last summer in
Winter Harbor on Lake wiip pasak um
close call High property damage where a
boat went through a dock and uh and
through a hacker craft antique style
boat that was at the dock uh that had
been occupied just moments before um in
addition to that though this could
simply be a bodily injury style um event
that could happen and we had one of
those just within the last couple of
weeks over on the wiip River so
what this does is it puts the onus on
the owner of the boat if the operator
fails to comply with the statute it's
not fail prooof it does still require
culpability so that means we'd have to
the state would have to prove
culpability that the owner did know that
that boat was involved in an accident
but if we could prove that then that
would give the state um some additional
teeth to bring those people accountable
that were involved with this voting
accident I'm happy to take any questions
that people might have about the
existing
statute so we will get to questions in
just one second for our committee
members um we thought that what you have
in front of you are actually the Senate
bills that were assigned to our
committee and uh Brad has been kind
enough to pass down copies of the bill
that were over there so we're all going
to just need one second because
unfortunately we haven't seen this yet
um my law book is in the other room so
we may need that as well um but let's
start is that's being passed around
I think I saw a ton of questions where
we at uh representative cig thank you
very much and thank you I know I'm
behind the speaker it's hard to see me
um so I'm curious um as someone who
votes on wiip there are a lot of uh
companies that rent boats um so
therefore they're the owner you know
various marinas that rent boats um and
so I'm curious just how um how this
would work for someone who you know how
how are they going to know in some of
these circumstances es to be able to
report if the I mean obviously there's
paperwork that they tell people they're
supposed to do these things but since we
know people sometimes forget to make
good choices I'm curious how that
relates back to
that great question so I'm going to try
to maintain eye contact and so you can
hear me as well um so I think it's
specifically to address your question
about rentals every time a rental comes
back um in from being used they do an
assessment on it typically they'll pull
that boat all the way out of the water
to check the boat for any signs of
damage um some renters find hard water
out there okay in other words they hit a
rock they cause some type of damage to
the out drive and then of course they
fix that the threshold in New Hampshire
is $2,000 worth of damage either to one
boat multiple boats or to include
property damage of something else a dock
is a good example of that so when that
happens um yes the owners then would
transfer to them as the owner to make
sure they're reporting it to Marine
Patrol uh so that we can investigate
that voting accident thank you're
welcome representative
Stone thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question uh looking at
this bill it basically kind of mirrors
the uh conduct after an accident Statute
in the motor vehicle code is that your
interpretation of
it yes sir it does if if we go far
enough back I'm going to say about 20
years ago there was a fatal boating
crash that took place in on Lake
winaki um and none of this statute none
of this language existed then and so
really although we knew the operator we
knew the boat we had nothing to fall
back on and so after that uh in the in
the wake of that this statute really
developed a lot of these reporting teeth
and the conduct after this simply just
adds another um piece to it if you will
to um again hold people accountable if
they know that the boat was involved in
welcome representative Newman yes hi
thank you I have very I don't have any
experience with boats but as in in
current uh um I guess in the current
time that we're in so many houses and
cars have security cameras do you see
that or are aware of that people with
docks or maybe even on their own boats
that have security cameras to help with
thing that's a great question uh on
boats no on some of your larger boats
perhaps what we are seeing more and more
of though are security cameras that are
fixed to people's docks because so much
of it can be done Wireless now and then
it goes real time to the phone the other
part that we are seeing is everyone has
a cell phone so if I cause a crash or if
I'm in any way involved because it's
voting related it's somewhat
sensationalized to begin with people I
think instinctually take out their cell
phone and record it I'll go back to the
event that happened this last summer up
in Winter Harbor some of the best
evidence that we had was was people's
cell phone footage so although not a
security camera I think it goes to in
line with what you're asking about thank
you welcome so just for committee
members that have never been on a boat I
will let you know that I was was
actually involved in a boating accident
once and friend of mine had a very nice
boat had a toddler and a car seat on the
boat and the boat that I was in was hit
by a person operating a rental boat and
put a nice giant hole in the side of the
boat that I was in and while we were
about to be hit with SBO the operator
dived into the water because he
panicked then his wife that was driving
the
boat pulled away left him in the water
because she was paranoid and panicked
because she was in a rental boat that
person knew that they were involved in a
wreck it was very obvious but had no
intention of letting the boat company or
the rental company know that they hit
the boat and I believe if I'm not
mistaken is that what this is like
addressing that's one of many examples
where this would be a app so the onus
like all criminal statutes right is on
the state to be able to prove that
culpability so knowingly does come into
yes
Muse I'm wondering how this uh uh
proposed Bill uh and and the
requirements for uh for owners uh
compare to I guess comparable motor veh
vehicle law um I think one of the things
that um uh I know I look for sometimes
is to try to make sure that if we're
changing the law for one thing we're not
necessarily doing something that would
be completely out of line with how we
handle it in a different area so is
there something comparable like this for
motor vehicle
owners I I would make the argument sir
that it is comparable in other words it
parallels it so if we had a motor
vehicle that was involved in an accident
let's say a hit and run and then they
drive away but someone had a cell phone
and they snapped the picture took a
video and they had the license plate and
then it comes back to somebody else if I
again if I can attach the owner to it
and the fact that they knowingly did it
in other words the vehicle wasn't taken
without their consent then I think you
have that Nexus and I think that this is
what this bill does is it cleans it up
and it um again allows us to be able to
go after the registered owner if that
operator for some reason is not
reporting so again this isn't um an
owner that is now a victim this is an
owner that knows that their boat was
involved and is simply failing to
report thank you welcome
Newman so let me just see if I can
summarize what I think this bill is
trying to do the operator has to make is
supposed to make a report and they if
they can't or they won't or they
refuse then as soon as as the oper not
the owner of the boat then becomes the
one responsible for making a report as
soon as they find out and if they fail
to do it and the change here is if they
fail to do it immediately when they find
out then they are then subject to the
Penalty and the penalty is a class A
misdemeanor and that was not changed so
it's only about the immediacy and who's
responsible for making the
reports that's correct sir thank
you
any any other questions am I missing
anybody's hands oh Representative
no thank you and um thank you for taking
my question um so I'm just wondering
especially when it talks about you know
somebody getting into an accident um and
um the owner needing to report um who
wouldn't necessarily be operating the
boat at that time I think in in some of
the ex all the examples that we've heard
so far there will be a lot of damage
with that um and you know I'm just
thinking about other examples that may
not cause immediate damage um and rather
than a rental it might be somebody who's
lending their boat to somebody else or
or other situations like that and so I
guess what I'm wondering is about the
burden of proof that that person
actually knew that that boat was
involved in an accident or you know what
I
mean that that's a great point and um we
can't completely mitigate that so um
that threshold for us on the Boating
side um is $2,000 worth of damage and so
if it was less than that um even if
damage occurred whether it be property
or to the boat now you're simply looking
at a a civil claim um best case scenario
um if it's injury related so beyond
first aid then that would automatically
trigger um that reporting requirement it
does not change though us having to be
able to say is the owner aware of the
the fact that this accident took place
and upon being aware of did they take
the action to report it um so it's I it
would not be accurate if I said it would
apply in all situations or if it's a
fail safe it is not okay thank you
welcome anybody
else set well thank you very much for
your testimony we appreciate it thank
it is there anybody else here that
wishes to testify that has not turned
into C all right well that being said I
will close the public hearing for House
Bill
1046 and to our committee members um
representative Roy is at the Senate uh
getting ready to testify on our bill
bills so we do have executive session
that starts at 10 o'clock however I
think we would all agree that uh me
opening and recessing the 10:00 hearing
or the 10:00 executive session in in
order for him to help get our bills
through the Senate is definitely a good
thing so with that being said I have to
be here to open our executive session at
10:00 but anybody that would like to go
to the Senate and tell them to pass our
bail bills uh if you just let me know
that you're going to do that we have to
we have to go into recess anyway because
he's not here representative
Newman at at 10:00 we are going to be
leaving and going to see the kids from
Charlotte Avenue schools so we'll be
over there for a while but that's right
acrossing the
Senate okay well so when he comes back
just so you when he comes back from that
we'll definitely have to go into
executive session so no I understand
that we shouldn't take long let's just
greet him and
whatever oh you you mean the school is
here visiting yes okay all right so
um that's fine
much yeah that's always a good thing to
so let's talk about this for a second um
does I feel like I'm in a classroom
right now I'm sorry does
anybody who wants to stay for recess who
is anybody that wants to go over to the
Senate and say hey please pass our bail
bills does anybody want to do
that I have to chase the bill in
Commerce okay you go chase the bill in
Commerce representative appr oh what
time you going to be back
represent this is so funny so when you
come back and start let me know and I'm
going to leave them a note to have them
text me when they're close to my okay
all right so my people will text your
people okay um representative wheeler
representative Reed you want to go over
the Senate you're staying okay read out
wheeler okay so representative Muse and
representative wheeler you're choosing
to go over to the Senate okay anybody
else want to go over just so I have an
idea when you know where we're all at
that's all you're repres okay all right
so I'm going to let chairman Roy know
representative wheeler hold on
representative Reed be quiet so we are
going um to let you guys are going to go
over to the Senate I'm going to let
representative Roy know that I'm going
to stay here to open our executive
session at exactly 10 o'clock and then
when he comes back I hope that anybody
that is also there comes back so we can
open up and begin our executive session
I think we're all on the same page with
that we all good okay all right nice job
that
I I think he said that the hearing
quickly
e
for
good morning everybody it is um 10:00 I
am going to open the executive session
for House Bill
1366 and I'm also going to immediately
go into
recess which we are now in recess um
actually I probably should have said for
those watching I apologize um we have to
go into recess because our chairman is
over in the Senate trying to or actually
not trying to he's testifying on the
house bills um the bail bills that we
worked on all summer and uh it is pretty
important to the public that we passed
those so anybody that's watching at home
if you could just you know uh do your
best to hang tight and as soon as our
committee is back from test testifying
we will reopen the executive session for
House Bill 1366 and make decisions on
recess
e
for
morning I'm opening the executive
session on house pill 153 9 and I'm
going to recognize representative
wheeler to make a motion thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to move a to pass on
HP
1539 is there a
second second and representative Murray
would you like to speak to your motion
yes please thank you Mr chairman uh I
don't think we need to talk about this
bill too much we got three bills on the
docket today and I think we may have a
opportunity to get out before 5:00 p.m.
which would be nice given how much work
we've done in the last couple of weeks
this bill is essentially a bill to make
sure that people who have rehabilitated
themselves and are out of prison and
people who
are trying to get a job again can have
their records un olded from uh a charge
which at this moment is uh be in the
process of being uh legalized by the New
Hampshire state house and by many
metrics for industry standards is uh no
longer something that they're going
after so we're we're hoping to get it to
the point where we're not as I said in
my testimony in a situation where we've
legalized and then people who and the
state is sanctioning smoking selling and
uh the use of cannabis while people are
still in jail for smoking selling and
using uh cannabis so and having that on
their records um this keeps people from
being able to get loans and Etc and
that's why we have an analment statute I
think the automatic analment statute
that's put in this bill which is really
the uh most important piece to my mind
uh is uh well crafted and done a good
job there only 6% of people uh in an
nments generally this is a national
statistic during get their an nments
they don't petition the court because
they either don't know or they are
unaware that it's available to be an
olded um so that's why it's important I
think in this bill to have that
automatic analment statute which would
not be an own Rous cost for dos as we
talked about in the testimony this is
not something that uh thousands and
thousands of people are going to be
eligible for very few people have only a
cannabis conviction on their record but
it's those people who are so wrapped up
in the system that they can't they
they've uh they made a mistake and they
serve their time and they'd like to get
that uh anold um it allows for re a
resentencing petition uh the Court's
standards on that are pretty high and I
think that we can uh you know I have
faith in the court system and the
Judiciary here to make sure that nobody
who has um any other and as it states in
the bill nobody who has any other extra
crime or anything on their record can
get that resentencing and that
resentencing bar even if it is just a
cannabis charge is very high as well um
so this isn't going to create any uh
crazy situation this is just going to
allow for people who want to be fully
functioning members of society again to
have their records cleaned from
something that uh We've determined is
decriminalized so with that Mr chairman
I will get off my soap box and thank you
for allowing me to speak and uh I
appreciate you for taking up this bill
um represent Murray would you like to
speak to your second thank you Mr chair
um I I think the previous speaker
covered it very adequately I would just
reiterate that um we did just pass a
legalization bill out of the house and I
always said I could not support
legalization without um anuling those
who have been criminalized for something
that were now trying to um allow to be
sold in the state so I do support the
OTP motion on this
Bill thank you um the concern I have
with this bill um is that it raised
is the legal limit of of cannabis versus
the what's already legal or I believe
even contemplated could you address that
I can Mr chairman so somebody would have
to serve out their sentence uh to
petition for Anan you could petition for
resentencing but like I just said that's
a high bar um you you
the in most cases somebody's going to
have served out their sentence and have
completed the sentence on what would be
a marijuana charge for uh 2 oun or less
and then that person uh can get the
analment but that's after they have
served their sentence so I I don't see
it
as uh legalizing as you put
it represent Murray you wanted to
address that yes thank you Mr chair um
so am I correct in saying that um this
isn't changing the current possession
limits because that's an a different
part of Statute and this is only related
to um The Possession limits that are
referred to regarding annulments correct
yeah and it's more it's more personal
use amounts for an for what would be
eligible for
annulments um represent Willie you had
just said that um the person has to
serve out their sentence but on line 30
of Page Three it says any person who was
convicted of any cannabis related
offense who has not completed their
sentence May at any time petition the
court in which the person was convicted
for
resentencing well I don't want to say
you misheard me but I I you might have
might have I I I I but I no it's not you
you're able to petition for analment if
you're still convicted but if you're
still convicted that's a much much
higher bar than if you're completed your
sentence and and that's complete there
uh so you're able to petition for that
but that doesn't guarantee that you're
going to get it from the court it
doesn't guarantee that you're going to
have your sentence resentenced it
get an analment it's just allowing you
to have that petitioned by the court and
anyone who petitions I would imagine
thinks that they have a case for getting
that
analment if if the the legalization bill
that we passed doesn't pass the other
body or isn't signed by the
executive is there does this still go
through or is there a trigger is it
connected did no this is a separate bill
that works in tandem with 1633 um this
system would ensure that people can as I
stated in my testimony get their
annulments and the 2 oun limit is
because people aren't arrested for 3/4
of an ounce and people were talking
about their cannabis charges being able
to sort of get you know as I said get
back into jobs get their loans people
who have uh rehabilitated themselves or
shown a path to Rehabilitation and uh
yeah so that's
no I guess for clarification what I'm
asking is if the if the legalization
fails right now it's still illegal
unless you have a medical card if the
legalization
fails this bill does not go into effect
and or it would because otherwise if it
does go into affect anyway this in in
effect legalizes it through the back
door saying well you can be convicted
but we're just going to anull it I'm
trying to is there a I hear what you're
saying definitely when we talked about
this in the test in in the uh hearing um
but it's a high bar to get your analment
it's a high bar to get your resentence
so it's it's not like you can just say
to the court I'd like it an olded and
the Court's going to throw you throw you
onto the streets out of jail you you
have to go to the court get your hearing
and then the court and the judge has to
determine whether or not you're eligible
for the analment or the resentencing and
when they do that most often we we have
a high bar with our court system we have
a good court system here I mean it's
going to take uh that person's going to
have to really have a case for an nments
to be able to to pass that bar so it
won't be everyone who's convicted for a
marijuana charge can just say oh hey
representative wheeler passed 1539 so I
can get out of jail free no it's not
it's that it's very clear what isn't is
not eligible for annulments in the bill
um
so all I'd have to say is the personal
use amount for eligibility for an nments
yes would be uh that but I it's not
it's not legalization because you're
still being able to be arrested
convicted sentenced and serve out your
full sentence if the court determines
that you're not eligible for an nments
which would mean that it's not legalized
thank you every time Murray did you have
something else to say Thank you Mr chair
yeah I would just add on to that that um
you know the position of the house has
been to support legalization we passed a
bill to do so a couple weeks ago and I
think if the other body chooses a
different position and itl's that bill
it's safe to assume that they would also
itl this one and so I think it would
make sense for us to move forward um
considering the position of the house
which is passing that legalization Bill
and that we also want to pass this
coinciding with that and if the other
body chooses different action then they
choose different
action I would um caution you against
using logic anymore
um representative Stone thank you Mr
chair uh I'll be voting against against
this bill at this time uh under R say
6515 we already have an analment
mechanism that's in place for all
classification of crimes regardless if
it was marijuana connected or you know
another lower level non-narcotic
possession or other various charges with
that said if you look at the statute
most misdemeanor A's and Bs are a
threeyear span of time from completion
of sentencing in which you allows you to
anal by petitioning the court uh since
there's a mechanism for analment already
I think it would be more prudent to look
at the an process in today's uh techn
technology is Advanced since this was
originally passed back forments and we
could probably streamline the process
but I really have a hard issue on
isolating just marijuana offenses for an
alment in addition I want to make sure
that we are only targeting you know uh
misdemeanor level offenses uh violations
I don't want to see uh felon level drug
dealing offenses being analled
improperly by passage of this type of
legislation thank you um representative
new thank you Mr chair um I don't think
anybody will be surprised to say for me
to say that I'm going to support this uh
OTP um but I just wanted to address I
agree with what representative wheeler
and uh representative Murray said um
about kind of uh the process and how
this works with the other bill I I think
there's a differentiation here in that
what this bill aims to do is to rectify
the past and we are uh when we talk
about um legalizing um cannabis we it's
essentially we are all agreed on the
fact that we should it's just how we go
about it what this bill does is say that
uh based on the premise that we
understand that part of the reason that
we are trying to legalize cannabis is
that there is a uh that we have it has
done um irreversible harm to people so
what this bill says is that on a base
level we understand that the uh the uh
criminalization of cannabis has done
serious harm to people in our community
and this bill seeks to rectify the p
whereas the next one uh the other one
the legalization moving forward um seeks
to rectify you know uh set things up for
the future I hope I'm saying that
clearly the differentiation between the
two bills is that one sets us up for the
future to to go forward in a good way
this helps us um reconcile what we've
done in the past and to um to write the
wrongs that we've done in the past
so representative s thank you chairman
Roy um I I also support this bill um
having previously worked in um real
estate and for a company that does
property management and knowing how many
people end up not being eligible to get
rental housing because of past criminal
records for something that in my mind
should not have been illegal in the
first place um to give people an easier
Avenue to get out of that so that it can
be easier for them to get housing and
also get employment so they can be more
productive members of society I think
excellent represent
read um I struggle with this bill
because I honestly don't want people's
lives to be destroyed because of a weed
conviction um however I don't think
anybody's being arrested and sent to
jail for much of anything these days
especially for a joint so I think that
they're being sent away for other things
besides this and um those who were
convicted or uh in the past for having
marijuana it was illegal back then we so
going forward we're we um marijuana
isn't legal yet anyway so this is like
putting the cart before the horse but
again I have to say I don't want
people's lives ruined for a weed
conviction but I don't know if this is
ready for prime time yet thank
you further comments represent
Muse yes part of the issue is I it is
it's not just a matter of people who may
or may not uh are be going to jail uh as
a result of an offense like this today I
think another huge issue is the fact
that this is an offense that just
follows people um there are people I
know who were arrested for possession in
college uh who haven't been able to get
jobs who've had trouble getting housing
uh it's something that uh that can
affect your whole life I mean we look at
this now as a as a minor crime almost a
violation level offense um you know we
barely prosecute people for under 3/4 of
an ounce of of cannabis now but it
hasn't always been like that and I think
until we change the law um so that we
actually align it with with where we are
today and where we seem to be today is
on the precipice of actually making it
legal for the state of New Hampshire to
actually sell it to people so if we
don't do something like this we would be
in a position as a state where we are
actually selling cannabis uh to people
and make bringing money into state
coffers to to do that but uh we would
have people who are still in a position
where they have trouble getting jobs
trouble getting housing um and you know
whose lives really have been permanently
turned upside down because we're not
fixing something that I I think should
point represent Stone thank you again
I'm going to go back that I heard no
testimony or supporting facts or
circumstances that led that the analment
process we currently had had been
availed and then the individual was
grieved by that process if we already
have an analment process why isn't it
being used for all these people who are
eligible to apply for inment and choose
sealed represent
Muse I think part of the reason for that
is that um the analment process has a
lot of built-in friction um it's
difficult uh I think for the average
person who's affected by this to uh
sometimes I think to even know that an
enement process
exists um it becomes something that uh I
think you can get as a matter of a a
privilege if you can afford an attorney
if you know what to do if you know what
strings to pull this is something that
you can do but it's not something that's
really readily available to the average
person who's been convicted of an
this
surely on the analment process you can
find that on the judiciary's website and
it's approximately a $300 fee that you
do not need an attorney to file for you
are aware of
that thank you um I think we can agree
that 300 bucks for some people can be
pricey um representative wheeler thank
you Mr chairman uh yes I I would say
that $300 can be pricey for some people
and also this bill is the automatic en
nment statute so I would say that it's
the government kind of doing its job and
saying okay here are these people who
have served out their sentence and now
we can get them annuled um we don't have
statistics for New Hampshire in general
but nationally it's about 5 to 6% of
people who are eligible for an nments
get their crimes aned because they're as
representative Muse put quite well not
aware of the system they're they're the
average American who's not in in
inundated with the criminal code and
probably doesn't even know that it
exists in a book form that they can read
and and you know I think that's most
people who don't uh grasp the system
that's around them um and that's why I
think it's important for sort of the
government to do its job in writing this
wrong and that's why that the automatic
analment statute was there um I respect
uh everybody on this committee and
representative Reed as well um the only
thing that I'd have to say to you is I
think it's sometimes you got to build
your cart so that you can travel down
the road you know and so I don't want to
put the cart before the horse but we
don't even have a cart yet so I'd like
to build this cart so we can take people
down the road here so we can make sure
that they have a a solid thing so I
totally I don't you know vote however
you feel you need to vote but I do I do
think um that this is a bill that's
separate from legalization you know what
however you feel about legalization this
is about sort of as representative Muse
put quite well people's livelihoods so
that's the last thing I'll have to say
Mr chairman and thank you for this
discussion and thank you for using a
cart instead of a Magic Bus analogy
um representative Harry GTH thank you Mr
chair but actually that's exactly what I
was going to talk about the fact that
this um if you look at line four and
five this is truly about you know
automatic annoing so he did a a
excellent job in explaining that so I
don't need to go any further and I will
be supporting thank you okay I think
we've um we've had just about enough
discussion on this one um I I'll close
by saying I I like representative Reed
am torn on this bill um however one
thing um as as it pains me to say
representative M's argument made um made
me think um how hypocritical that we're
contemplating selling this product and
people people have a criminal record for
possessing the product that we're about
to sell um I I don't think I can that
doesn't set well with me so I'm I'm
probably going to support this and um if
it passes on the floor and let the
Senate deal with it how they deal with
the other Bill and in their wisdom maybe
combine these to somehow come up with
something that's proper but I just don't
um that bothers
me representative Newman and I just want
to follow on with your comment I mean we
haven't decriminalized many other crimes
at all this is a unique situation where
we decriminalize something where people
have a record and so it's different than
than the other crimes that are out there
and I support the automatic uh
solution um to be clear just to go on
record I'm not a supporter of
legalization at all but I'm a supporter
of common sense in law and whether we're
talking about marijuana or widgets if
the government selling widgets and
someone has a record for possessing
widgets to me that that's that's that's
not um that's not right but say I will
disassociate myself from your previous
comment no problem um representative
Murray uh would you please call the RO
motion on the floor is odd to pass Vice
chair rhs no representative Pratt no
Representative
yes representative love no
representative
Reed this is really hard for me you can
cons I'm going to go
yes representative Stone no
representative tzar yes representative
Harriet GTH yes representative Muse yes
representative Su
Newman yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler yay
chairman
Roy chair votes yes 146 146 the motion
about to pass carries representative
wheeler um I expect you to write the
report and be ready to argue this on the
floor against representative Stone who
will be writing the report for the
minority and
speaking so that that bout is set up
when do they do buy um ASAP because this
is crossover next week I can get that
tonight um actually what is today
Wednesday yeah you got 40 minutes to
meet the
calendar we're going to take 5 minutes I
know we've already been missing that was
because we were held hostage by the
Senate but we need to discuss one more
bill before we take it up both parties
are requesting if we could uh
please
e
I'm opening the executive session on
House
Bill
1366 and I'm going to make a motion
introduce an
amendment and the amendment number is
going to be
011h can I have a second
second by represent
Stone I'll speak to the amendment this I
really don't have much recollection of
this bill other than the fact that I
apparently got an amendment for it and
I'll read it Reckless operation of boats
any person who shall operate a power
boat are you guys okay over there no
we're not M Mr chairman representative G
did we already except this Bill yes
confused on January 19th that might be
why I have no recollection we're all set
it passed pass as amend it so it so it's
on I think it's on our list is this
Groundhog Day no no no no no no because
remember or if I remember correctly um
we had to recess it because we had to
fix the do we already know this am I
repeating people because we had to fix
the the fact that it was in both
statutes it said I mean both uh sections
that said the same thing we and then we
recessed it so that we could have an
amendment that that fixed it and we did
get it so the amendment number is 0111 H
I believe this is the am that's been
handed on January 19th okay we did 0111
H2 to0 then we did ought to pass 20 to
zero so I don't know what all right
we're gonna this was put on here by IR I
no no I'm not redoing it I spoke to um
our assistant and she's the one who gave
us this to go on the agenda so I'm going
to recess this non-existent bill for a
minute could you ask Karen do you mind
thank you yeah thanks and in the
meantime we'll take up something much
less controversial I open the executive
1711 and I make a motion of ought to
pass second who second and that
representative here I gu right oh
that I'm going to uh I'll speak to my
amendment I mean to my bill so this is a
really really difficult
bill but at the end of the day it comes
down to a simple
concept um as all of you know I am one
of the staunchest Second Amendment
defenders in the
house that being said I cannot with a
straight face tell someone that someone
who is dangerously mentally ill should
be able to walk into a gun store and
purchase a
firearm someone who hears voices telling
them to do things someone who who has
these dangerous
inclinations and has been found so by a
psychiatrist and a court with an
attorney at a
hearing that's the person I'm talking
about I don't know how I could tell the
family of Chief ha or any of my
constituents I think it's okay that they
can buy guns now I understand
that anytime you seed power to the
federal government it's a very dangerous
thing that being said
the federal law is already in place once
you have been
adjudicated
dangerously mentally
ill and committed and that's what this
bill is about people who are committed
for the most
part you're automatically a prohibited
person whether you know it or not or
whether the state informs the federal
government or not if you're arrested and
you have a firearm you are subject to be
prosecuted for a 10-year federal
felony so there's that aspect of it the
second aspect of it is this right now
anyone in this room could go see their
therapist tonight and tell their
therapist you know I'm so mad at my
spouse I could kill them if they think
that you might be serious they can
report you to
Nyx and there you are you're on nck
you're on the list and guess what you
can never get off ever there's no
process in New Hampshire for the
restoration of
Rights for for the federal government to
take your name off of Nicks your state
has to have an approved approved rest of
restoration of Rights
statute that means you write a bill it
passes in law the ATF looks at it it
meets their criteria they say it's
approved now you can get your name off
the list New Hampshire has no such
statute so anyone on the list right now
from New Hampshire is there for the rest
of their
life so at the same time we have people
who are dangerous being able to purchase
firearms in Hampshire and we have people
who may no longer be dangerous unable to
get their name off the list so that they
can purchase
firearms so what this bill
does it makes a very narrow process to
have someone's name sent to the federal
government and it gives them a way to
get back off that list I also due to
lack of trust with things at the federal
government level sometimes put in there
that this law cannot take effect until
after the ATF approves our restoration
process that means if there's no way to
get your name off the list your name
can't go on the list so I took every
step I possibly could to make sure that
people's rights were protected and that
only the people who are dangerously
mentally ill and having been a judged so
by the court with a representative a
lawyer and if they couldn't afford what
want is prevent uh provided for them
would be put on this list only people
that were already prohibited by federal
law from possessing a firearm are going
on this list and even they it's only
temporary and if they get better and
they have their treatment they can get
off the list so with that um I have
nothing further to add representative PR
second I do uh
so I agree this is not the perfect bill
but it does uh head in the right
direction uh people who are seriously
ill uh need not be able to have access
to
firearms and I also like that we're
putting in restoration of Rights so
um if it's a misunderstand standing with
your therapists you get better right
because we all know that the end goal of
of therapy
and and mental health medicine is to get
you better get make you stronger um and
a lot of times it's
just uh one issue that you work through
and and you're come out the other side
in a way better place than you went in
so um to be able to get off that list
after you um
gotten
better is significant I think so um I'm
going to vote for
this thank you representative rhods
thank you Mr chairman if if you one of
the things you did not touch base on
that I think would be
helpful is an example of where a red
flag lot is different is an example if
if somebody were to call up and say you
know say it's a an ugly divorce and
and there's an accusation made where a
red flag law would be different than the
situation that is here if you could
maybe talk about that for just a second
address that sure red well depending on
which red flag ball um generally
speaking Heros um those laws what they
do is they allow someone close to you a
family member friend neighbor to be able
to go to law enforcement and say that I
have serious concerns about this
person's mental health at which point
they can issue the the police can get
what's called an erpo emergency order to
pull your Firearms it kind of flips the
script in other words it makes you have
to prove your sane versus the state
having to prove that you're not sane um
whereas this law that's revers the state
has to prove that you are dangerously
mentally ill instead of you proving
you're not so that's one of the key
things and second thing is not everyone
can just go in and apply for you to be
involuntarily committed it takes um I
think it takes people I mean it's very
complex to get somebody committed in a
state it's not easy and someone off the
street who doesn't like your politics
can't just go in and say I think that
person should be involuntarily committed
so it's it's a much much different
standard between the two and I would add
that as far as proun States it's
difficult to think of two more proun
States than Florida and Texas and both
of them have this exact law
representative
Newman would you just clarify your
motion was ought to pass or ought to
pass as amended there is no Amendment
associated with this okay so previous
you um represent
Muse I just wanted to briefly uh speak
to the amendment because I believe we
have to vote on the amendment first uh
representative Newman just said that and
I I you'll have to excuse me I I have an
amendment and it's for this bill I just
whose amendment is it
mine it was a February Amendment and it
was you we have an amendment dated
February was it was entered that day at
the hearing when I was gone I don't know
entered I thought it was entered while I
was
gone
this was the amendment uh representative
Roy that um the uh disability rights
Center uh proposed uh and it has some
pretty significant changes that I think
are probably changes we would all agree
to um yeah I recall it and I thought
that it was introduced already that day
that I left and the hearing continued
because I had to leave so we will um we
will introduce the amendment so I
believe my motion was out to pass I need
to withdraw that motion we need to
introduce the amendment um
representative approve thank you the
Motions are withdrawn I recognize
motion I move to uh pass uh uh HB
17711 with Amendment 2024
0431 H I second that would you like to
speak to that Amendment
please one of the I think one of the
main objectives we've had throughout
this process is to make sure that
whatever we do doesn't further victimize
and stigmatized people um who are
already victimized and stigmatized
enough and and those are people with
with mental illness uh while it's
absolutely critical to close um a
critical Public Safety vulnerability I
think one of the things we've tried to
do every step of the way is to consult
with people in the Mental Health
Community in the disability community
and even with some of the the folks who
work at New Hampshire hospital on what
this bill should look like and how it
should take shape so as part of that
process uh Karen Rosenberg who is the
policy director for the disability
rights Center uh noticed some things in
the bill uh that she suggested fixing
that would make make it um uh
essentially easy easier for her
organization to sign on and and I'll
just review some of those things very
very
quickly um one of the things the
amendment does is it requires judges to
inform um uh the person um who's under a
judication uh that uh a seizure is a
possible outcome and it makes them aware
that they can request a hearing on
involuntary commitment and they can also
make other arrangements to turn in their
firearms rather than Simply Having
uh a law enforcement officer confiscate
the Firearms another thing that it does
is it reduces the time frame for the
process um that guns would be returned
uh to someone who's proven that they're
no longer a danger to themselves to
others uh the original Bill uh had uh
had a six-month time frame for that to
happen the amendment reduces that to 60
days
um the uh the amend
uh also uh restricts some of the sharing
of of personal information so uh the
original language basically said that
any non-clinical identifying information
uh could be shared what the amendment
does is it restricts the sharing of
personal
information simply to the information
that's needed to get somebody's name up
on the system so that would be their
name um it would be the applicable uh
prohibition it would be their date of
birth and their social security number
so no clinical information of any kind
uh is actually being shared uh with the
FBI or any anyone in the federal
government uh that information is
retained uh in the New Hampshire
judicial
system thank you representative Muse and
thank you representative Newman for
bringing that to my attention I was
absent the day this um bill was brought
forward so I thought I left the
amendment I thought it had been adopted
cuz as you as you may have noticed in my
in my discussion I mentioned some things
that were already in here so um having
said that further discussion on the bill
and the underlying Amendment we didn't
discuss
yeah representative Stone yeah on the
bill itself uh I support it about 90%
And with that being said I'm going to
support uh making a motion excuse me not
a motion but I'll be voting in a yes to
send it to the house floor with one of
the aspects of this bill that it really
uh stands out to me is the process of
duw process that both removing firearm
rights and reinstating fire Mar which is
crucial an individual should not have uh
due process stripped from either
direction whether it be in the beginning
or the end uh this bill does rectify
that in addition a judicial process is
involving an attorney that is there to
represent a individual uh the attorney
will safeguard their rights as well
during the hearing process the judge
will make the final determination it's
not just a psychological or medical
issue that's brought up so the due
process provided by a hearing is
instrumental in providing individuals
rights and that's uh the best takeaway I
have of this Bill thank you I would um I
would call everyone's attention to the
fact that um in 2016 representative Hull
introduced a bill that became law as
part of the Medicaid bill that
specifically said no one shall have
their firearms taken away by reason of
mental health ISS issues unless they
have a hearing before court and they
have an attorney
present um which is basically what this
does except it also gives you a way to
representative thank you um thank you Mr
chair committee um I I support the bill
and the amendment I used to live in a
community where we had an Indigent
person who suffered from a recurrent
mental health illness and he would get
hospitalized he would get stabilized
with medication once he was stable for
two weeks they would release him because
that was as much coverage as he had for
insurance um he would then cease taking
his medications and we'd go through the
cycle over and over again until he each
time got to the point of attempting to
break into a business or do some other
kind of thing that frightened people and
then would end up back in the hospital
back being involuntarily you know um
committed and and he's the kind of
person who this addresses right he
should not he was not able to maintain
stability in a way that kept him safe to
be in society and because we don't have
a structure to provide him the type of
life support or overall life support I
don't mean like breathing but
functioning support um in our society as
as it exists right now he would not have
been someone who would have been safe to
have a firearm because we would never no
one would have ever known when the
voices were telling him to do things so
I think it's a good bill I think it's
essential that we work to protect people
and and that we have a process to
protect all of
them thank you further
discussion seeing none um the motion on
the floor is to adopt the amendment um
and I'd ask the clerk to call the role
vce chair roads yes representative Pratt
no representative culum yes
representative PR yes representative
love yes representative tutor yes
representative Reed no representative
Stone yes representative tzar yes
representative Harriet gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Su Newman yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
saling yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair yes 18 two 182 the
motion is
adopted I make a motion of ought to pass
with
amendment seconded by representative PR
I believe the discussion has covered
every aspect unless someone has
something they want to add that wasn't
said I would ask the clerk to call the
RO the motion on the floor is up to pass
with Amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt no representative
kcam yes representative PR yes
representative love yes yes
representative tutor yes representative
Reed no representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry Gite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Su Newan yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sake yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy shair votes yes 182 any
objection to
consent seeing none it will go on
consent and I close the executive
session now I'm opening the executive
session on that
last apparently I was right in the first
place on hb1
1366 about crazy boat drivers where are
we
at Mr chairman it appears that we are
all a little bit right and wrong uh so
we did vote on this bill and we did pass
it um on the consent I believe was 20 to
zero with an amendment and we if my
understanding is if my memory is correct
we actually made a motion to re I think
we like withdrew the motion because
there was I believe something with an
amendment and representative n seems to
have a better memory exactly but I do
know on my list I crossed it off so I
know it was taken
back uh our lovely assistant has um
informed me that exactly what I just
said we had the we did vote on it and
then I crossed it off so we turned it in
knowing we were going to come back to it
today but I don't remember the reason
but representative n seems to if you
I um I apologize I don't have the bill
in front of me right now so I'm just
going to give there was an A and A B and
we had an amendment to separate the A
and B because uh they were different
levels of offense right so um but when
we separated it out we didn't change the
language in a way that comported with
those being two different things so
there was one one phrase that was
repeated in both that really needed to
just be in one and I'm sorry it's not
specific because I don't have it in
front of me if anybody does I can tell
you
exactly okay we're trying really hard
not to have too many people
talking it was the or no no no no no
yeah okay
so in the amendment it was in a reckless
manner or so that the lives and safety
of the public are endangered I think we
were supposed to get rid of the or uh I
can't find it my notes but whoever spoke
about it wasn't recommending the war in
between those it it was our um there was
a sub from Judiciary who had been the
both of them both of both A and B oh he
was very explicit that the way that it
was written made it unclear would make
it unclear for a Justice to know what
the full intent was and that we needed
to remove the word or in order to have
it correct and I I am sorry that I've
lost his name in my memory moment
actually he is the former Chief Justice
of En Hampshire Supreme Court
um so it's because having that
phrase so that the latter that that the
lives and safety of the public are
endangered having that phrase in both A
and B uh make it so that those are
equivalent so it's it's hard to parse
out so we needed to take it out of one
of
them and I have an amendment in front of
me
011h and I'm not sure if that does that
it
we we reest it so that it could be sent
back to have the or removed and we
forgot yeah so we do not have the
correct amendment that does today so
okay um first of all just anyone
watching at home we are not normally
this
messy the the
Senate the Senate held a hearing on one
of our most important bills this morning
and um it really kind of threw a wrench
into our structure um yeah so having
said that we are up against the deadline
on this bill um so I recommend that we
vote on to passw with Amendment as it is
and we can fix it with a floor Amendment
AB um just so that we have it off our
table at this point represent Murray did
we when we recessed it did we not
already land on OTP did we not already
vote on that I think we did and but
maybe we didn't transmit it to the clerk
correct so if we've already voted I'm
just going to say transmited and we're
done yeah if we voted okay hold on the
approaching okay what we're going to do
is we're going to call the role in O
passes amended we're pretty sure it went
20 to Zer but we can't be sure so we're
going to do a belt in suspenders so I'd
ask the clerk to call the role of O
passw with Amendment on this bill just
to cover us and um we will look at
fixing it on the
floor so representative Roy you had made
the motion of ought to pass so we'll
just go with that okay ought to pass
yeah with Amendment yeah second it
please second all right ask Clerk
coloroll
Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative kokum yes
representative pu yes representative
love yes representative tutor yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harriet GTH yes
representative Muse yes representative
Su Newman yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes represent
ative Newell yes representative sck yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
CH yes 20 20 motion passes um it'll go
on consent except for I'm going to have
to pull it to do an amendment what ought
to pass with Amendment um but it will
not go on consent because we need to
what
all
right so now we have to do out to pass
with Amendment same vote same deal um I
make the motion representative Harry G
rooll
pleas chair rhs yes representative Pratt
yes representative kcom yes
representative PR yes representative
love yes representative tutor yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzar yes
representative Harriet gther
representative Muse yes representative
Su Newman yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sake yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 20 okay 20
Z motion carries uh here I close the
executive session and the next time
representative ly Subs I'm going to
assign a representative to stick with
him and write down and take amendments
from all his little judicial Pearls of
Wisdom he leaves us with um with that we
are good until uh I'll see you all
tomorrow and next Wednesday we start
taking up Senate
bills and I believe we
have wait a minute hold on what which is
oh that I'm sorry that's right 10:46
um while I was over at the Senate we
heard that let's just dispose of that I
O exe open the executive session on
House Bill
and I
recognize representative rhods to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move out
1046 priority okay would you like to
speak to your motion thank you Mr
chairman uh so
basically this morning we had basically
heard um that it's there there appears
there are some situations where people
possibly could be renting uh Motorcraft
and if they're they may be involved in
an accident they're turning the boats
back in um there may be an aggrieved
party but there isn't anything um Coming
forward to say so basically the person
runs the boat and leaves and it's very
obvious that the that there has been
damage done and nobody wants to say
anything about it so this actually does
put a threshold of
$2,000 um and it also clearly says
reasonably or reasonably should have
known um and he was very much able to
explain what should have known actually
could mean um I had given an example of
a boating accident that I was in a while
AG years ago that kind of explained what
this kind was about and there was only a
couple questions and I I think it was
very very much straightforward there's
really nothing bad about this at
all that was a word solid but you get
would you like to speak this a second
represent Pro sure I I think it just put
some responsibility you know like you
would have in a in automobile you get in
a car accident and you have to report it
and now they just say if you're in a
boat accident more than $2,000
damage anything it touched you have to
report it so that's common
sense further
discussion seeing none motion of floor
is ought to pass ask clerk call the
rooll vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
culcom yes representative PR yes
representative love yes representative
tutor yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenar yes representative Harry goth yes
representative Muse yes representative
Su Newman yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative
Newell yes representative sik yep
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
CH votes yes 20 20 any objection to
consent seeing none we're going on
consent motion carries with that we are
done till next Wednesday except for
session
e